you know it's weird i've been flying
quite a bit i was just in chicago for
jack brunch jackbrunch.com we're going
to new york next weekend come check us
out
and i don't wear my mask at all on the
airport the only time i wear it is when
i go through security
and then as i'm going to get to the gate
when i go on the plane and you know how
many i've been to miami i've been to
las vegas i have been all over and do
you know how many times anybody's ever
said anything to me absolutely zero
it seems like nobody in the airport
really cares until you actually get on
the plane
and on the last flight i was on the the
captain came out and instead of the
flight attendant making the uh the
little spiel the flight the captain
comes out and he's like look i'm
supposed to say this real long thing but
i'm just going to tell you the way i see
it and he goes we have to do this and if
you turn my flight attendants into the
mask police i'm going to throw you i'm
going to send you to the cops he's like
it basically he was saying it all sucks
please don't make my flight attendants
who are just trying to earn a living
turn into some sort of masked nazis like
he didn't say i had to ask my wife
afterwards i go did he say masked nazis
because because that was the vibe that
he was putting out right the captain
when have you ever seen the captain get
out of the cockpit come into the
corridor and make an announcement
pre-flight i fly a lot so you don't fly
anywhere dude no i i used to fly twice a
week okay right but but not premium
platinum top tier i've seen the the
captain's come out yeah totally and i'm
sitting up front as well too but it
struck me not not for something like
that because i've been it's the flight
attendants reading the thing but like
nobody in the airport wants to enforce
it
nobody wants to nobody wants to enforce
these things and back in march of 2020
when the first match i think you're
wrong that's possible they do want to
enforce it i haven't i haven't seen it
felt it or anything i think they want it
to be enforced but no one really wants
to yes they do they do want to win who's
they i mean that's the guy who came out
and literally said i'm enforcing this
right now but jack was just saying he
didn't he seemed like he didn't want to
be he seemed to me he was defending his
flight attendants which is the problem
which is the problem that i have with
all this is that all these mandates have
deputized normal ordinary people into
becoming the police and these people
want to do it yeah let me explain
something so uh a story you may have
heard me tell when i had a friend say i
wish i could do what you do i want to
travel the world and i say okay buy your
plane ticket and go travel the world and
they were like well i don't have the
money for it what do you mean you got
this fancy apartment in brooklyn like oh
well i mean you know i don't want to
lose my apartment i'm like because you
don't the the you want
the apartment more than you want to
travel so when someone says i want to do
something but they won't do it they
don't want to do it when someone says i
don't want to have to do it and they
literally do it yes something made them
want to do it defending his staff that's
what that's what i felt like his
motivation was and i can appreciate
i can appreciate that i can appreciate
not just like i don't want to be bullied
into taking the vaccine i don't want to
be bullied into bullying my own staff to
do things what would happen if he didn't
do anything
he would be cited and fined himself by
the tsa how would the tsa even know what
happened somebody would report him and
then he'd be like you know we didn't
even know he was doing it we yelled at
him he wouldn't listen yeah i'm not so
sure about that or how about this he
just says i don't care
i'm not so sure about any of that but
look i've noticed that the enforcement
is invaria is variable too i had one guy
be like you must put your mask up in
between bites and sips and he said it
like five times in between bites and
sips and then on this other flight they
just don't care so it's it's individual
in some ways but i hear what you're
saying about collectively speaking no as
an individual that man wanted to enforce
it on you i think you can have so you
can have conflicting wants like i want
to eat a sugary cake but i also want to
be healthy so i don't eat the sugary
cake this guy i'm breaking it down very
very simply had a choice
enforce mask policy or don't
now just because his motivation for
doing so was external coercive pressures
does not mean he he didn't want to do it
he
wanted to
more than anything else you're
highlighting the major issue here which
is that the government is putting us all
over the fire
they're saying basically what if you
want to drill all the way down what
you're saying there what you're saying
is that guy wants to feed his kids
and the risk is is he's like look i can
feed my kids
or i can come out on the mic and be like
please put put your masks on
i think that if and that's a terrible
horrible crappy thing to do to a guy a
private citizen a guy just working i
hate the fact that he's been deputized
to enforce this nonsense by threat of
not of starvation of his children
but but see that
what are you gonna do if someone said
i'm sorry someone said to you basically
do this or your kids are going to starve
tim where are your morals there's any
troubles in my day so that my children
will know peace thomas paine said that
in common sense
anybody who's willing to sacrifice the
future of their children doesn't
actually care about them
look i get it they say tim you don't
have kids you don't understand i'm like
okay fine whatever i'll just tell you
this i tried quitting fusion you know
when i worked there and they were doing
woke garbage i went to the present said
caught my contract i don't want to be a
part of this and he said
well you know we'll come back we'll talk
about it so i couldn't do anything and i
can respect that like i did not agree to
enter awoke company and do woke garbage
and then once they started doing that i
said i won't do it and so i didn't do it
and they basically just had me in golden
handcuffs if
if if i was a pilot
and they said do this i'd say no
and they might well did they fire you
right away okay fantastic
great it's not fantastic for people
that's the problem no i understand i
understand i don't care i understand
this black and white like division i i
get it i totally get it and i'm in a
luxury position
uh where i can make the same statement
uh most people are not most people are
not and in fact in fact my luxury is
running out because the mandate now is
going to be
that all varsity athletes in high school
have to get a vaccine in montgomery
county maryland where my kids go to
school
my son is a high school baseball player
my daughter is a high school high school
rower
and if they want to continue on in the
sport that they love
playing for the school that they like
and that they go to they're going to
have to get the vaccine what am i going
to do what do i do then tim
did i tell my kids forget baseball get
crew yes
man i wish you luck i wish it was i wish
it would love the system more no
no then tell your kids not to play
baseball what
dude that's like telling you not to wear
a beanie and not to do this show no it
isn't yes it is exactly that no one's
mandating i get vaccinated to do this
show but if somebody put a gun to your
head and said look you're gonna die or
you have to take off your [ __ ] beanie
excuse me i take it off if if that's the
fate that's that's the same thing for a
kid in high school who wants to play
varsity sports whose whole life
as a kid has been like i want to play
varsity baseball is not real life
baseball is not survival baseball is
something reigns
and it is a path to success it is a path
to scholarships and you care more about
that than your kids no i care about my
kids because those things are valuable
you care more about the fact they could
play baseball than the health and
choices of your kids and their freedom
if someone if first of all they don't
have the vaccinations if i went to a
skate park and they said you can't come
a skate park once you're vaccinated i'd
go a skate park i know but i will go
into a parking lot go to another parking
lot there's no other place to play
varsity sports then stop playing
you see this is it if you give people
something they will have something to
lose and you will own them that's from
the villain in fast f fast and furious
so your solution is to never
have anything valuable to you no
that's that's that's a kathy newman
oh get out of here that's an inside joke
and that was a major insult you ready to
go i didn't i didn't say
you can never have anything valuable i'm
saying when your family's being coerced
you stand up and say no
and you're what you're saying is well
they're gonna make my kids do it and the
system in place that they control and
the things they've given me are more
important than my sovereignty so be it
you you
you can you can buy a farm you can
choose to work hard and be and be not
that simple man you know what i wish i
had that simplicity if it were up to me
they'd be homeschooled and playing
private club ball all the time but guess
what i've been divorced for 12 years i
don't have sovereignty over that
particular issue i can't just pick my
kids up and move them across the country
right i don't have sovereignty yes
so what are so what am i supposed to do
your issue is that the decision over
your kids in the school they go to isn't
yours correct it's the states due to a
conflict with
life yes so the whole system has got me
down man and so what am i supposed to do
is my line in the sand gonna be
taking away from my children the thing
that they love the most well how the
hell well i don't you want to say that
14 16.
if it was me yeah i'd do in two seconds
you would tell your you would tell your
kid that you have been coaching in
baseball your whole life that you have
taught how to throw how to pitch how to
bat and you've talked your whole life
about them being on a varsity sport and
going into college play division one
baseball and you would look them in the
eye and be like just throw that away
because daddy's got a political position
you think your kids being forced to
undergo a medical treatment is a
political position
the statistics show very clearly that if
you take the vaccine you're pretty much
gonna be fine the statistics also show
if you don't take the vaccine you're
pretty much gonna be fine so i know that
this is nothing but bullying it's
nothing but bullying and they have found
that open wound that open nerve that one
thing that i can't fight
which is the happiness and success and
fulfillment that my children feel they
won you're right you're going to live
they've won
i know this yeah so what am i supposed
to do about that tell your kids stop
playing baseball dude
just wait till you look your own 16 year
old the others i'd be like daddy's got a
political point to make so you have to
be miserable no that's that's an
oversimplification no it's not it is
it's fair to say i don't have kids so so
perhaps i don't share you know
understand the emotion you're feeling
but uh let there be troubles in my day
so that my children will know peace it's
not a political position to defend
freedom and stand up against tyranny
that is a responsibility especially for
an american but
being the best division one baseball and
being a successful baseball player is
more important than choose that and just
so simplifying it man sometimes men and
boy boys and men need a vocation in
order to become a mature adult
and right now for my son in particular
being a baseball player is how he's
learning responsibility how he's
learning discipline how he's building
his body how he's learning about
nutrition how he's learning about risk
taking how he's learning about courage
strength loyalty being a good teammate
all those things are more important
they're more important than personal
freedom and sovereignty when i don't
have a choice you do have a choice you
just don't want to admit it you don't
want to admit it bro actually actually
at the end of the day i'm not going to
have a choice you know why because if i
take this all the way down to the final
road she's going to go to court she's
going to get a court order the court's
going to bring in their physician the
pediatrician is going to say that the
the kids should get the vaccine and the
judge is going to order it and that's
going to be that and you'll have stood
your ground
well i have stood my ground so far and i
do anticipate staying on my ground as
long as i can as far as possibly long as
i can until the absolute last drop dead
point where i have to like rip the
dreams out of my kids brains and hearts
and crush them and make them cry in
front of me
that is that is that is as far as i'm
willing to go and how many conversations
i can't tell you how many conversations
i've had with people who are like i want
to travel the world and produce
documentaries and work for these
companies and i say
well then you've got to make sacrifices
and they say no the state should give me
the money no they shouldn't how about
you get rid of your apartment do you
like so much but i've worked so hard to
finally get my own place to have my own
place to call my home i deserve this and
if i want to be a journalist and travel
and travel the world and do these do
this do these things i shouldn't have to
sacrifice having a place to live
that's some bitch-ass [ __ ] that's
nothing that's nothing that's this is
this is life that's nothing that's
nothing that is that is making decisions
between i want to drink beer or i want
to drink water i want to work at this or
i want to do that that is somebody's
choice okay we're talking about
government compelled vaccines and
medical centers to fight orca and i do
and i will fight it as far as i possibly
can but i'm what i'm doing is i'm
acknowledging that that i will do
nothing but fight
and it will all be in vain because i
know the entire system is built against
me i am fighting tim
i'm fighting every single day and i'm
gonna fight you know who i'm talking to
right now if you're watching i'm gonna
fight all the way to the end
okay you know who i'm talking to i'm
gonna fight all the way to the end the
point i'm making
is that i i do not accept people coming
to me
using words to to to to
to uh state how they feel about
something and then immediately doing the
opposite proving everything they said
was
[ __ ] when someone says i just
wish i had chocolate cake and i'm like
there's all the ingredients in front of
you i'm not going to make it so you
don't really wish you had it you're not
willing to do what you need to do
i totally understand it if the vaccine
had a 20 rate of paralyzing kids
obviously this choice would be much more
clear
right those negative side effects of the
vaccine are almost the same as the
negative side effects to getting corona
it's the they're very close we're
talking about 99.9 percent did you say
or ninety nine point nine percent of
that you see the study that said that
there's a higher risk of myocarditis
then yes i i read that of course i have
a history of pericarditis i have a
history of heart inflammation i am
completely zeroed in on this issue in
particular that study was pre-print it
was look i tweeted that study i was like
yes to this study it was pre-print it
was not peer-reviewed it was only on
120-day hospitalization rate and it had
some stale data okay it wasn't perfect
people been tweeting out like it's been
perfect but it wasn't a lot of it a lot
of the stuff people have been tweeting
out to counter the vaccine mandates are
like
imperfect it's all imperfect and this is
why i want more time the rate of change
in the data is still so great but let's
let's slow down this is not about the
vaccine no this is it's about being
compelled by the government to do things
that you don't want to do exactly
and so the issue is
the issue the issue is do i want to make
my political point for the uh on the
blood of my children no or do i have an
alternative route where i can make a
political point that has more impact
with less negative side and less
negative side effects and maybe i'm off
cutting out excuse me maybe i'm being a
bi tch in this matter you just said the
f where i know i'm sorry dude but but
like my point is it's like
sometimes the cost-benefit analysis when
it comes down to it when it's your kids
hopes and dreams and for me
i have alternative avenues right like i
have a show i have an audience i have
influence i can make things happen
i haven't i have a way to impact the
world that doesn't revolve around me
sacrificing my kids
well how are you sacrificing your kids
by if if i if i refused them ultimately
at the end of the day if they were if
the only choice they had was vaccine or
athletics and i said no athletics to
them that would be sacrificing them but
there's other ways to engage in
athletics
uh
one one would one can yes if you move to
florida if you move to west virginia if
you move to texas
but again i'm hamstrung
i'm screwed
what do i what are the kids how they
went what do they want to do what do the
kids want to do they want they want to
play varsity sports and they don't want
to be bothered by this
are you how do your kids feel about
getting vaccinated
my son
you know he's as based as it comes so
he's kind of like i don't know maybe i
should maybe i shouldn't my daughter's
like i don't care i just don't want to
be hassled yeah
this is how because they're not informed
they don't really know so this is this
this is why i quoted the fast and the
furious villain when he said give the
people something to lose and you own
them
imagine what life would have been like
for you and your family 300 years ago
you wouldn't be in this conversation
you'd be like if my kids are going to
eat they're going to go break their
backs in the fields all day with me yeah
now you're like my son needs to play
baseball
don't
mock it like that no i'm not trying to
mock it but let's put it there are very
few places in this world today where a
young man can learn virtue okay
competitive sports
is a place where you can learn virtue
courage
honor
loyalty how about an mma gym
vax mandate in dc bro
what what am i supposed to do they're
boxing me in in every which way possible
well
without leaving the uh learning virtues
practicing virtues there's there is a
political statement of it to itself
there's three states outs within like an
hour of dc i mean actually virginia and
maryland are like literally
in dc basically you just some some you
can live in dc and like cross the street
and be in in maryland or virginia indeed
and then it's an hour to west virginia
where they don't have these things and
you could go to like a gym or whatever
the point is man what i'm saying is
yeah it sucks but if someone tells me
like these things are wrong however
baseball's more important i'm like just
say it
no
character development virtue
yes all of those things
through baseball that your son learns
are more important than
like standing up to you talking about
building for the future
building a child that is virtuous is
courageous is honorable is loyal is
loyal
is perhaps more important for the long
term than making a political stand in a
in a losing battle today it is a
tactical retreat
so that you can be stronger and better
for the future yeah but if we go this
route there's not going to be a stronger
better future it's going to be continued
capitulation by more and more people who
refuse to make a stand look i'm getting
texts that the comments are calling me
blue pill and teaching submission and
stuff like that fine i'm sure people are
telling me i don't have you guys a few
guys okay wait until you're in my exact
particular position and you have to make
these calculated decisions this is why
they're doing it they're doing it to act
make us go through agony yep
life agony thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time